you
we're ready to roll here let's have some
fun twenty-five of you are entered let's
see what kind of arrangements we get I
wish there was a little countdown for
the chess960 games so you don't make
sure so like you don't overstep so you
don't overstep the 25 second thing this
was my idea I want my my knight here
I need to move my queen so I could
Castle kingside
so that's what I'm gunning for
looking for this kind of stuff Bishop d2
here queen f2 King side castle that's
the quick sketch each blue thank you for
the subscription I appreciate the
support it's been I believe a record day
thank you let's go is d3
this Bishop can easily find some some
way out here it's gonna have to not
coming out this way it looks weird
Firefly I know it certainly takes some
getting used to twitch is owned by
Amazon yes it is thank you
just JK for the sub okay let's go in for
it I think this is the right way to do
it and one nice thing is that with the F
file opened up as soon as I cast I'll
kingside my rook will be optimally
placed let's recapture
queen of two castles
Kalas - thank you for the sub enjoy the
little icon and yeah thank you so much
for your support
Queen F - and the emotes you I didn't
know that there was a little smiley
faced in the in the upper right of the
chat where you could just select the sub
emotes instead of typing them out it was
not aware of that so I still need to get
one more piece involved have a time edge
against a frequent viewer player
terminal so let's see do you get the
money from the twitch prime so I'm just
like regular subs yes same same thing
it's uh - two dollars fifty cents a
month I don't know of any different I
believe that's that's outruns oh let's
see
so the immense I'm gonna get distracted
thank you for the sub how about I'm
gonna go here I think is best
yeah I feel like he'd be in the line of
fire here so the king is now gonna be
brought out and now let's improve the
night we got some checks maybe this in
here I think their king is in some
trouble let's start with this check
maybe I was a bit too fast with that
let's go with this and then drop my
Bishop all the way back
okay how about we make a fast move oh I
had another check I should have
considered that oh no no no no let's do
it now not here I have the bishop pair
let's hang onto the bishop pair let's
get it let's get a knight traded huh
this Knight here could be annoying
similarly that could be annoying you get
the a I get to be mm-hmm I could kick
him away I have this square
haha
all right let's do this if this pot ever
moves I have this square let's improve
the King sit this pawn Oh
got a pond I have a pond so I'm open to
exchanges now let's cover this I also
have a bishop check let's just throw
that in right here
I don't want to take I need to
reposition let's cover this square and I
have one night exchanged
where's that nightgown let's take the
night I have the better bishop
my king could enter he's entering its
box the King out first
17 seconds
okay now
push through
you
and get that pond 11 seconds
they're being sneaky oh I thought I made
the move they're down on time vac
determined tough game terminal thank you
to wrath Prius for the donation the
stream so also adding your videos have
helped me become a much better chess
player and thank you for your excellent
chess play in the company commentary
thank you for that rath Prius
it's a broken record but again I
appreciate the support thank you for
that
okay ah one game in no one has to that I
see from the first two pages let's see
that okay sack of Sasquatch all right
let's sue no time to waste here we have
every every position is pretty unique
yeah huh well I think I want to start
similar head-on
okay hmm
yeah I don't think I have a better spot
for my nighty there he is in the corner
isn't he not too many options for a
corner tonight now yeah I'm concerned
about my bishop as well I don't think my
knight wants to go here at the same time
this is now a window for Bishop here
because I was fearful of this move so
now I'm basically doing what you would
see in like a Carol con which is getting
a bishop outside of a pawn chain so this
and then this he's my bad bishop
so f6 he's free oh and also I was
thinking that this was the queen
hmm tell you what tell you what I can
just take yeah I'm gonna go with that
and then look for this move
I want a Castle queenside similar to the
last game what happened I had the F file
open up and then when I Castle kingside
my rook was playing similarly if I could
get my Queen out of the way when I
Castle queenside this rook will end up
here I couldn't go Kings side as well
because this is this is a fine now this
is a fine structure - I wonder how to
release the Queen a5 Queen here I don't
want a weakened light squares because
this guy up will give me a problem um I
think this is fine I like that I'm
restricting the knight some and my queen
has a way out let's get my Queen here
don't want this night to get too active
or even a step foot on c5
what I understand what that moves about
let's open this up maybe that was a
mouse slip no no my pieces are now going
to fall on very nice squares my knight
will be here soon queenside castle
let's keep a watchful eye over this
square I think I want to go Kings side
actually this could be annoying and I
think the most convenient defender is my
king so maybe here in this kingside
castle let's do this
threatening pretty devastating stuff
with night see for now night on III I
don't think you could survive that yeah
I have a very good structure ties in
well with my bishop all my pieces are
soon to be playing King I'll have safety
let's go Kings side rook here soon this
rook well I don't know yeah I think I'm
more inclined to go with a in a four
move then I would be an F pawn advance
so I'll keep this rook here and occupy
the open file with my F rook so yeah
I'll look to probe over here this is a
situation of opposite sides castling
pretty much so I'll be looking for a4
next let's do it I'm about a minute edge
okay they're looking to break up in the
position however I could take here and
then take here I don't want to get I
don't want this to happen let's take
first and let's take yeah let's take
here because now there's gonna be an
issue
this nights gonna be unprotected
they're just realizing that now okay I
could take the rook and I'm gonna be up
a full rook now close to it
yeah
I don't know my guess is that there was
a I don't know king d2 seemed odd I
don't know I don't know they had a
question mark next to their
rating I don't know if I was related to
not having enough experience with 960
because I know when I first started out
I was unsure how to Castle exactly so
maybe tried to pick up the King in
castle or something but it seemed a bit
off the king D to move is what I'm
getting at
Jason Ches account all right let's focus
a new new position all right I think I
like that as a start as well both nights
probably here let's see what to do with
the bishops okay that's a very
challenging move now I could probably
say or do I hold my ground
I'm gonna take and shoot for some rapid
development so grabbing a tempo against
the Queen
I need to move my bishop how about this
oh yeah I'm gonna go at this move let's
open this position up I have a lead in
development and ever so slight lead I
just take let's take first and then they
hear oh hello I got that move right out
of left field skewers
how about that
I have anything better than taking the
rook I don't think so
now we're cooking pile up on that pinch
piece castle and everything is looking
looking good I think I could take away
and then follow up with a c5 move chop
incoming c5 get the piece back still up
the exchange and a pawn
let's take with the rook move forward
with an attack I can improve my knight
let's get a flight square first this is
a desirable flight square dark square
that queen is a bit annoying what does
white want to do bring the Knight to c3
so let's interfere with that and improve
my knight and more probably improve my
queen right around here there's nothing
fancy happening if there was a bishop
here there would be a tactic with Queen
takes rook bishop here and then rook
mate but not right now that's not
happening now I could force the Queen's
off Queen f4 yeah let's do that
keep my night in the center I think I'm
Queen takes Queen I'll take with the
rook what's huh are they listen you
listening to the stream I think direct
there was an admission my pond what's
listening to the stream yeah that's what
that was you saw instead of resigning he
was just like maybe hinting hey I'm
listening I'm listening nice right here
yeah alright this one should go pretty
smooth I'm prepared to Castle kingside
right now I want to be careful this this
pond could be a bit scary let's go here
with Bishop e2 in this
solidify my strong point in the center
and I guess they're preparing that yeah
even so you have some checks maybe there
let's get in see for right now be a
little bit careful and some I've had
games where the Queen gets trapped out
of the blue yeah you know what I'm
getting at
all right let's castle
of d2 rook c1 Bishop d2 the symmetry
here
pawns Knights for both of us king and
rook same story let's put the rook
opposite the Queen I don't think she
could feel so comfortable here it's no
way they're also the same diagonal so
this is something for both a bee for
advanced ant to support a bishop before
this contributes however indirect it is
to controlling the center let's do that
takes here takes hmm that weakens this
square can I make use of that let's
let's take here first if the pawn takes
I have Knight f5 so I have to take it a
piece most likely
you'll probably take the night well okay
ooh I have Knight f5 hmm they may try to
shut things down over here I want to
make sure that that's not gonna happen
let's make sure this file opens up I
want to make sure my rook d1 move is
purposeful and he plays a role let's get
my bishop on the long diagonal I don't
want to do this just yet
he could be improved
a queen on f5 maybe she's probably close
to being trapped it's a hanging pawn
structure well let's do this I have h2
covered
even go here for Queen here she has to
still watch the night because I think I
will
I could cash out I can maybe even do
stuff like this like right now I could
play Knight to h3 I might be a move go
with Bishop takes Knight as well don't
have much time let's try that I guess
and then I could offer a queen exchange
actually no yeah let's go for that move
oh I don't have much
I got it I got a I got a really focus
here
down 23 seconds okay queens are off I
want some trades get my rook on see the
night moves I have this I can take this
fun in some cases Knight g5 this Knights
out of play hmm
all right I guess have to do that now I
could have played here light square
bishop exchange I need a flight square
but no this night could be captured
maybe let's do this I caught up on the
clock oh let's weaken the d4 square hmm
let's target this flight square 92 it's
going to be a rat race
okay it's run III chase that night away
open up day trial get my rooks attacking
okay I can grab a pond and improve the
King defend no mates have one second
down on time
tough game man tough game mmm I think we
both did pretty well coordinating our
pieces with that arrangement okay I got
white this should really get your mind
working it must be said it really gets
your mind working whoo okay let's start
with this and
hmmm I think I like this move opens the
Queen opens the bishop my bishops
already defended
I like these two spots for my night okay
I can exchange Queens whenever on my
terms let's start with this move I don't
want to give this option open allow that
option so soon my bishop could already
come out here where's this Knight headed
all right let's get the knight here now
let's see if they really go for this
okay now I have this move but simply
block I could Castle queenside I'm
forgetting how it would end up can I
also go with this move should I get more
development in before I do this they're
not going to castle this way so I think
hmm this still kind of scares me some
this might be an idea somehow
now if I do this the night can be
captured
huh okay Wow I spent so much time on
that move I think this is a good reply
yeah good move so let's listen who
they're taking with the bishop I wasn't
expecting that
um let's go here small pond center hmm
Hedgehog like I don't want to do this
because then I have to worry about my a
pond I need my queen around to defend h2
and also go for this but I think I like
this move this is more challenging well
it's a strong piece in the center maybe
even this is an idea now it gives up f5
this guy cancels out the night I want to
keep him here
Wow alright let's go here
that's so weakening light squares Bishop
is knifing right into their position and
he's not there to watch over it alright
now alright let's make sure I could rely
upon this night now maybe take here well
definitely if the knight takes I have to
do something about this this pawn is
pinned this rook is unprotected so let's
queenside castle now all my piece is
playing I like my structure I don't know
well 45 second double my time
oh I got the rook that pollen was pins
they just blundered there mmm I'm okay
what a queen exchange all right let's
just take someone out 33 seconds time is
the biggest issue
kick the night in push here looking for
Maine on this diagonal
you
let's do it
running-mate night here could break this
up though yeah let's cover this square
and then here okay how's that covered
I nearly pushed here and loud the Queen
to do this can probably grab that a pond
um I want to smash through on c6 I'm
looking to sacrifice a piece night on b4
I have a time edge now okay
Knight takes c6 incoming and I'm hitting
the Queen when I do that now the Queen
night with check I am on the Queen but
this is leading to me Queen right in the
corner I could pre move they resigned
back to tournament yeah I thought they
played it well up until they played that
b6 move soon as there were some
weaknesses there near their king I mean
my LightSquared bishop that was in the
corner there his eyes lit up
without question light square weaknesses
okay alrighty 25 minutes left in this
one we're tied here 16 37 players in
this one 16 with fire
yeah seeing the chat instant d6 yeah I
mean if I'm playing if I'm playing what
is it d5 I definitely want to make sure
I could play d6 I mean I'm not playing
d5 to just clog up that diagonal that's
two pieces I have you know train there I
don't want it to be blocked so what do
we do here I probably want to start the
same yeah he'll be developed just by
moving the pawn
just as my opponent is doing however I
think I want to stop this advance so
let's first go with the night oh there's
this Bishop takes poem of that I didn't
see hmm
they didn't see it either all right we
both had that kind of idea I didn't do a
scan at the beginning to see what's
unprotected and I should have all right
to Castle kingside I just need to go
move the bishop to Castle queenside I
just need to move the Queen this seems
like a good idea it controls so many
squares from the Knights yeah this is a
very strong pawn
I don't want them to get this break in
they could try something like this to
really try and force that through but it
is wasting some time
going for that they are going for that
so if I was i interfere with it though
you know and we're gonna take with the
night that's not as well placed again
wanna watch out for that so they could
try for this there they go for it I'm
leaning towards going uh let's secure
this pawn this is gonna hit and I just
want to be able to move my knight want
to make sure he stays around so he go
forward let's try this first throwing a
punch here and if he's kicked he'll go
to a fine square on c6
now I have some concern about my bishop
being blocked in by a white pawn
chaining and f-4e five structure which
is maybe being lined up right now I
could take and do this to be careful now
Queen here
yeah cuz I don't want this square to be
given up what about capturing and then
playing 'if I've think I like that
there's also some possibilities here I
don't want this move to hit let's do
this
my opponents ready to queenside castle I
want my Queen here I want to control
this Knight if I could control this
Knight
okay I could give this check now this is
good get to develop with tempo and now
I'm ready to Castle queenside I may want
to take on that for first let's see how
light addresses this check with a queen
block okay take here yeah I want to play
against it and I either an isolated pawn
or a hanging pawn structure both are
good and right around this point I may
not want to Castle queenside if like if
the Queen's are off I may want to go to
d7 I think this could be a fine home I
am preferring this No well maybe there
is a fork being if I Castle queenside I
end up in a phono no no no no I think I
should Castle queenside yeah if I go
here when they queenside castle this is
a threat so now probably rook here
attacking upon 55 seconds this if I have
time for it they'll probably give my
native Boop where what do you want to go
see how they defend this pawn though
first no if then okay can I not just
take that pawn for free let's go bishop
here first
yeah I want to challenge this night 38
seconds to a minutes bullet mode always
a scary opponent whenever you see that
question mark you really don't know
they're there 960 strength played a good
game
evening out on time now 35 seconds let's
challenge that night I guess this is
lined up I think I could get away with
taking a pawn now how did this square
covered from checks sake with the pawn
keep this covered as well let's
recapture
yeah my night out of the way let's just
defend and stop this secure my night
chase the bishop away you improve the
King watch out for Forks hmm yeah it's
gonna be a time win at this point tough
game
tough game interesting arrangement yeah
all right I got 20 with fire two up
there
20 with fire 18 in change okay what's up
Lucas Pro Dan in the chat melody knock I
okay let's try this to be careful with
this pawn I'll be I'll defend that with
Knight b3 we have to be a little bit
careful here let's
first I know where my knife belongs
pretty sure and I think I could go here
where's where is all this night going on
a bishop check well that's wasting some
time and I have a convenient block
another thing he has a better spot than
g3 let's get this night out the they've
both moved but they're both not well
placed could use some help
where do I want to go with my King it
seems like Queen side is the most likely
can grab some space can I maintain that
phone I think so let's go for that
if if challenged I do have f4 who so
there's a serious hole right here I want
a dark square Bishop exchange
let's move my bishop here I feel like
I'm winning
if I get a couple moves in like moving
the rook and then I could Castle
queenside okay this was what I wanted a
dark square Bishop exchange so now let's
put my rook now let's get my Queen out
here support the pond and address this
kind of move can that move still be
played though Queen here Queen takes
pawn how significant can this pawn be I
think white black runs the risk of
getting the Queen trapped if they did go
pawn hunting here Queen f2 Queen takes
pawn some Bishop move is threatening a
Queen trap they're really locking it
down here hmm makes me think I could go
Kings side let's start with this move No
do I do a castle no I do I capture I
mean no because I don't think I could
get to this week square in time and I
want to be able to do that maybe this
was better there is this a knight c-4
move which could be annoying he needs to
go somewhere else let's improve the
night
this isn't a bad move let's do it
I'm gonna challenge my knight no let's
go here now here my knight probably
wants to go here at some point it's just
exchange in between her possibly yeah
it's possible isn't it okay let's hang
on to that pond and my king is gonna cap
I'm in a castle by hand we're gonna
maintain this pond here still good
control there Knight isn't doing
anything
let's get him here and then Don f 3 less
than a minute for me huh all right let's
take because now I have this square for
my night let's back up my queens there
to defend King has a bit of a shaky
position their night King cannot get
into play easily
okay yeah let's do this I'm going to
look to camp out on c5 securing a spot
for my knight ok this pawn is pinned
now I'm clearly better now that that
Queen is out of my territory clean
exchange
okay here and then let's take they could
grab this pawn now whoa
they don't want this fun let's just stop
that knife from going anywhere
twenty-two seconds right to a six
inching in now I want one rook traded
their night continues to struggle even
on time look for g4 next and now f5
still f5 I have to watch out for pins
okay this is an issue let's target that
pun also blockade and I could get rook
to e8 in as well I'm winning that pond
just come all the way back there down on
time back to tournament got 24 that guy
still matching me 24 24 with fire
someone in at 19 terminals in at 19 with
fire
okay one more game maybe two let's see
all right yeah they could have grabbed
on c3 okay this is oh this is the pack
leader hang up first move first we will
first move critical critical critical
all right let's start with this do you
for
right here hmm this is a tough
arrangement
this one's tough oh I could know what to
fene keto I could go with the fiend keto
yeah let's do this I'm just dying up
this sensitive square I have it covered
all right oh did not see that but this
shouldn't be so bad this is um I can do
this don't want to take with my king I
want to keep castling castling privilege
open I think they're realizing that this
is maybe a mistake yeah I think my my
night is fine with this cuz bishops eyes
are open
c4 Knight c3 King side castle and launch
all these pawns it's my plan I can also
look to establish a knight on this
square now it should be a good strategy
I can start still with c4
I wanna get Castle kingside let's start
with c4 Knight c3 and then castle long
huh King side long to be concerned about
this square this is this is blacks right
now
you
I don't want a light square bishop
exchange he's an important defender be
three Knights III they will capture that
pawn I'll play it as a pawn sack I'll
undermine it would be three I like a
Benko gambit style in a way I'll get
some open lines in this direction should
I challenge that right away I probably
should let's do this right away so I'll
get some play for my Queen in my rook
and I'm soon to have all my pieces
playing okay so they're just not gonna
capture here I could play III and I
probably should could take that night
but now my bishops too valuable it's
hanging on a d4 this could be annoying
they could try to make use of this gap
in my position on d3 but right around
this point even giving up an exchange I
think might not be so bad let's just
scoop up the fun do so with the knight
yeah let's do with the knight ah both
are interesting actually if they go at
this point their King is really I'm
doing it for the rook purpose and they
suppose I could go here I have play for
my rook their queen is still in the
corner
you know kingside castle soon good
structure bishop fits in well could
really exaggerate this structure son
with c5 really trying to get here let's
let's just get a castle I tried to
target this front now I've night to be
five maybe I could have got one night to
be five right now all right where's the
night headed yeah he's really just a one
move threat piece it's improved the
Queen ever so slightly
Knight to be five soon rook to see one I
have the safer King time is evening out
seven minutes on the clock
game clock tournament clock tempo tempo
now I get that pond so this should
collapse and its wits tempo still Queen
has to go to one of these to maybe clean
exchange
Hawaii rook here I want to be able to
challenge that clean she is short on
squares no doubt my knight is
unprotected his queen seems like she's
gonna be trapped very soon just to go
here I can't sir but you should not be
able to survive that double attack
against the Queen got everything covered
light and dark she's surrounded all
right Queen is gone let's take the
bishop get the knight out of my position
trade get the rook next he's in a pin
let's take him this was an idea and move
forward move forward Forks and there we
go it's for mopping up at this point and
we'll grab a Brook the rook enter check
and then mates all right
took him down he is still in first
though 28 28 23 I have fire guy in first
well then I just played does not have
fire so if I get this next one with five
minutes left
I gotta go fast I have to try to get
this win in for 55 he's unprotected this
is probably a good idea fianchetto let's
start with this if I did this this is
scary now let's go here um okay you're
gonna Castle kingside right away I can
already castle we could have both castle
down our first move 28 28 23 for 23
to play fast I can't use all of my time
this can come down to like 30 seconds
each this game won't register for the
tournament this isn't any bother I just
castle and I'm defending my 7th ranked
squares the key 7th ranked squares let's
go here they're preparing to trade dark
square Bishop so I don't want that
let's castle and let's get night on v6 I
want upon out first though and I want a
light square bishop exchange Bishop f5
and this move I have c4 on this move
okay let's just see if I could induce
some pawn moves now let's come back
let's defend here three minutes 10
seconds gotta go faster yeah rook here
both my rooks here
now I can move my night at least 248 can
only use about a minute left of my time
okay I'm winning upon I am winning upon
one Swan II just want some exchanges
LightSquared Bishop Soph get that dark
square Bishop 108 to 200 8 on the
tournament clock can get upon major
peace ending I'm up to ponds let's give
a check
Queens off I'm fine with let's keep it
really simple it should be a 1 King and
pawn ending let's stop King here should
be a 1 King and pawn ending improve the
King ok I'm glad they didn't go after
that pawn let's just box out there King
they should be running out of moves soon
45 seconds now I get this passed pawn
should be able to do this and let's just
make sure the King doesn't go any
further
they were being sneaky there I was ready
to do that one minute
three seconds and they have 38 and they
resigned we did get that one in there 32
that did it got that one in there 53
seconds
left and I think that's gonna be it I'm
not going to get another pairing okay
how many games is that nine nine games
let's have a look at this one while we
wait
sack of sasquatch playing his team white
22 seconds before this ends yeah this
one isn't going to end that's a really
well entrenched tonight they're made on
g7 you got to be careful of this stuff
the right Queen exchange all right let's
get back over that's it all right
32:28 27:22 45 players in this one let's
look at page two three four and five one
of my favorites chess960 all right to
the 44 of you good games all all rights
you